starwars you're killing me here so it'd
have been my intention to put up a
review for it which I just saw but no
Star Wars news had to break so I kind of
got to talk about that first because I
did a video talking about cone Trevor
leaving episode 9 and now they have
brought in and confirmed the director
and it is JJ Abrams and I kind of went
through sort of a personal little
rollercoaster trying to figure out how
exactly I feel about this um the first
thing I'll say is right off the bat it's
not a bad choice there's no reason for
me to be fearful of this choice but sort
of nailing down exactly my thoughts on
it it took a little while because pretty
much when I first found out I was kind
of I was kind of mad on it because um JJ
Abrams well first of all let me back up
the force awakens I like quite a bit he
did a good job of doing what that movie
needed to do which was bring back the
fun of the original Star Wars trilogy
and remind us of all the things we loved
while giving us some places to move
forward from and he did that he did that
very well and I do like the force
awakens but I remember thinking oh boy
I'm really glad somebody else is
directing the next one because while he
sort of got us back to where we needed
to be in terms of this franchise I
didn't have a ton of faith that in terms
of him taking the reins to move
everything forward so the idea of him
directing the next one well not the next
one immediately but the directing
Episode nine kind of made me go uh I
think about the fact that I was glad he
wasn't coming back for eight and I had
to sort of wrestle with that but then
again I'm it's my hope that what Ryan
Johnson will bring us in Episode eight
is going to propel it more in a
direction that'll be a clearer more new
direction as it turns as opposed to just
being mostly a nostalgic exercise which
again if I'm being honest a big part of
the appeal of episode 7 was it's
value as a nostalgic exercise so maybe
with you know the the imprint and the
force and the and the impact of somebody
with a I I hope more original and
forward-looking vision for Episode eight
hopefully that'll that momentum will
carry through on JJ Abrams is work in on
the ninth one and it's my hope that Rian
Johnson will at least assist with
scripting in that I don't think there's
been any word on that who knows but it's
a it's a it's a pic that makes sense
because I in and what it does is it
brings some stability to the process of
making Star Wars because right now of
the of all the source projects that
either have come out or have been worked
on the only ones that have gone smoothly
have been episode seven in Episode eight
rogue one massive reshoots Han Solo
replaced the directors in the middle of
the darn process you then episode nine
chucking the director before you started
shooting so at this point but before
getting JJ Abrams onto Episode nine it
was looking like we were gonna have more
more Star Wars films where there was
problems than ones that went smoothly so
it makes sense to go back to someone who
can has in the past made it work
smoothly
I suspect they probably asked Rian
Johnson first will you do the next one
and he probably just wants a break I
mean JJ Abrams himself said after he
finished episode seven yeah I I want to
take a break so I have a feeling that
him coming back on this is a little bit
like Joss Whedon coming in for Justice
League I'm not sure it's a job he would
have picked for himself but the
circumstances sort of made him go you
know what I feel a responsibility
towards this franchise and it's
something I want to see done right so
they're asking for help I will help
because that's the vibe I've always got
enough Whedon taking over Justice League
is that it's more the circumstance that
sort of pushed him to do it and he
probably would have turned them down if
they just asked him at the start and I
kind of feel the same about JJ Abrams
NEP
so nine and maybe that's that's the
right headspace cuz it means he's gonna
be interesting going there and
delivering something that is going to
honor what the the franchise is going
for it ends that's certainly what
Lucasfilm is gonna want because it does
seem like they are butting heads with
directors who have ideas where to take
it that's not where Lucasfilm wants to
go with it and the again the exceptions
have been JJ Abrams and Rian Johnson so
yeah it makes sense it's not a pig that
gets me excited not that Colin Trevorrow
had me excited Colin Trevorrow kind of
had me nervous but ryan johnson has me
excited cuz he is a guy you know very
much has his own vision and he's always
put his own stamp on everything he's
done JJ Abrams is a bit more I'm not
gonna say he's a guy without a sense of
style but it does seem like his
prevailing skill is making things look
like other people's movies you know and
that's that is why he was actually a
really good pick for Episode seven for
what the franchise needed at the point
that movie was getting made so yeah he's
I can't get excited about JJ Abrams
being tied to it but I'm not nervous and
I feel like okay this will go smoothly
from here I guess my only worry is that
it may not be excessively adventurous
but depending on how episode 8 comes out
that might affect what my expectation of
what episode 9 could or would be in the
first place though the other thing
tacked on to this is episode 9 now has
had its release date push back from
summer of 2019 to December of 2019 which
is where it should have been in the
first place
Disney why were you moving these to
summer you've got carved out December
for yourself why would you get what I'm
glad for that move because as far as I'm
concerned that's where it should be at
this point anyways so I think that'll
about do it JJ Abrams back for Star Wars
yay ish I mean it's good it's good news
it's not bad news it's just yeah
the guy doesn't excite me but it's it'll
bring stability
and right now star wars kinda needs that
so those are my thoughts on it what are
yours whatever they are drop something
down on the comments let's talk about it
don't forget to like subscribe check me
out on Twitter at Council of geeks give
a listen to the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]